i got my first number one album bro i
feel good man i feel real
good congrats thank you bro 25
yeah what what made you want to go with
that uh
you know i turned 25 back in october and
you know it's just just life and
you know the position i'm in right now
is surreal bro cause i lost a lot you
know along the way
a lot of course people i love didn't see
25 years old like when i was
i always be saying like i just said it
more than one time
like when i was 18 17 years old and like
one of my older guys
like from the neighborhood to turn 25 we
just started calling them og like yeah
you og status now
which is crazy it's crazy it's hard to
see 25 you know what i'm saying
it's a real milestone so for me to be 25
years old and
and accomplish so much and reach this
much level of success in my life and
to still be modest about it because i
know it's so much
[ __ ] out there that i still want to do
you know
i feel like uh just where i'm at
and all the emotions i went through
recording this project and just you know
beating so much [ __ ] like everything
every obstacle ever came my way in life
bro i just found a way to get through it
like not complain or
not want to give up or you know what i'm
saying like not wear that [ __ ] publicly
you feel i'm saying i just i just deal
with it you know what i'm saying and i
think when i turn 25 bro i'm like
i'm not lying like it's like a switch
just went off i just i just
started thinking different and
everything like literally as soon as i
turned 25 i was like
i ain't gonna say i changed but it was
like some images
made me think about everything
differently bro so yeah man i feel like
you know
amongst your peers like in you know at
least my perception from a fan's
perception is like
you seem to have your head on your
shoulders real straight like
you know the last few years you really
don't hear your name and no
goofy [ __ ] you know what i'm saying like
and the same can't be said for a lot of
the guys who are around your same age
doing the same thing you know what i
mean so
kudos to you i feel like you've been on
your grown man [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying no for sure i've always been
mature you know i'm saying i always hit
a level head
and you know thought about [ __ ] a little
differently you know i'm saying that i
take pride in that bro i ain't trying to
be known for no goofy weirdo bozo
especially in this industry man a lot of
[ __ ] like that take place man you know
like
[ __ ] be having gimmicks and [ __ ] like
that and it just oh no it don't really
it don't work out bad yeah right bad for
him bro so it's like
i'll just be trying to focus on me i
don't chase nothing that's not
funny you know i'm saying i'm not trying
to be like the next artist i'm just
trying to be
me bro like the best b i could be and i
win doing that like [ __ ] all that other
[ __ ] 100